well hello everyone it's been a little
while so what's been going on and where
have I been well keep watching cuz I'm
going to tell you all about it so this
video is going to be a mix of personal
updates and some things that have been
going on in the professional scene and
part of that is going to be an update on
why I haven't been making videos lately
and what I'd like that to look like
going forward let's start with the
personal so since the last time you saw
me post on here I got married so now
when you see me make lots of hand
movements in front of the camera I'm
going to have a ring on one of my
fingers so there's that another thing
that you probably notice is that I'm in
a completely different room with a
completely different setup well that's
because I moved twice actually so the
story there is for basically my entire
life I lived in the Detroit area I grew
up there I went to school not too far
from there and then after I graduated I
moved back to a different part of the
area for work and then the big sickness
of 2020 happened I'm still not sure that
I'm allowed to say the name of that
thing without this video getting
demonetized during that period the job
that I was in went fully remote and then
I switched to another job that when I
started it it was fully remote my wife
wasn't my wife at the time but she had
just gotten a new job at Nashville that
required at least some kind of presence
in the office and honestly I've been
looking for some kind of reason to get
out of the Detroit area for probably a
couple years by that point I just hadn't
yet brought myself to do it yet it's far
from the best data science job market in
the world and honestly the winters there
just absolutely drained the life force
out of me like for years I get through
February and I think this is absolutely
terrible this is the last year that I'm
going to deal with this so honestly when
I got an opportunity to move like that I
jumped on it honestly the circumstances
behind it were perfect because I had a
fully remote job and I could go wherever
I wanted want to but moving is a ton of
work you have to physically pack up your
stuff for some things you have to move
it yourself or some things you hire
movers for you get to a new area you
build new routines you build new
community there was just all this stuff
that had to fall in place and we had to
move twice going once to an apartment
and then we just recently bought a house
after that where I think we're going to
stay for a little while but something
else happened shortly after coming here
too remember I noted that I had a fully
remote job well this wasn't really
working out for me all that well now to
be fair it did have its share of
positives so I got working in a totally
new tech stack I was working in a pretty
interesting hdfs based environment so I
was learning new things and I had tons
of pretty interesting and talented
co-workers but one of the problems for
me was that it was in the adtech space
and I found it very difficult to get
myself really passionate and fired up
about it I've seen myself in the healthc
care space before and how passionate I
got about that so the difference that I
saw in myself was sort of Night and Day
the other thing and I remember I've
touched on this in other videos in the
past but I never have been really crazy
about fully remote positions now I know
a lot of you out there you have them or
you really want them yourselves but you
do have to be a little careful about
what it is you wish for from a few
experiences of my own it can be very
difficult to get the support that you
need and there's something to be said
about out of sight out of mind so now
you probably see where this is going now
just over a year ago I made yet another
job change I'm now in an amazing
opportunity as a senior data scientist
at a giant company based in Nashville
and it's a hybrid position meaning I go
in the office about 2 to 3 days a week
and I'm remote the rest and it's been a
fantastic experience I'm back in the
health care space that I'm really
personally passionate about I work with
great people and I've been learning a
ton and that's really where a lot of my
focus has been for the last year or so
so when I haven't been doing all this
crazy personal stuff like planning a
wedding or buying a house I've really
wanted to focus my time and attention on
learning for starters I had never worked
in the Google Cloud platform before and
now that's basically all that I use and
I really also wanted to grow my
expertise in the machine learning
engineering and devop spaces so just
recently I got certified as a Google
Cloud professional machine learning
engineer but I can make a whole video
about that topic now I've talked about
this ad nauseum and other videos that
I've made in the past but if you work in
the data science space continuous
education and constantly upskilling for
yourself is critically important so this
is really something that I wanted to
focus on for myself after honestly
having felt it slip a little bit for
about a year or so this is another topic
that I can make a whole other video
about but the type of work that I've
done as I've moved from one role to
another has changed radically like just
for a simple example I moved from one
position which was kind of a mix of
python and R to another position which
was all R to now at this point I
literally don't remember the last time
I've opened R it's been all Python and
SQL for me recently it's been so long
since I've used R Studio that last time
I did that was when they branded
themselves as our studio instead of
posit so to put all this stuff together
the reason I haven't been uploading
videos over really the last year is
because there was just all this other
personal and professional stuff that had
to take priority but I was also sort of
running out of things to share and stuff
that I wanted to say that's far from the
case now now I feel like I have so much
to say I don't even know where to start
for reference the last time I uploaded a
video on here that was before chat GPT
and llms took over the world for me
anyway as I'm sure it is for a lot of
you all too my energy and passion in
this space has not always been a
monotonic function so just like the
market and the underlying field there is
excitement there's hype but there's also
disillusionment and cynicism so now with
some of this other stuff under my belt
as long as I feel I have things to share
and life allows me I do plan to put out
content as routinely as I can when I
started this channel just over 4 years
ago now I stressed that getting into
data science is a challenging but it's a
thoroughly rewarding and enjoyable
experience and my opinion on that hasn't
changed matter of fact it might have
grown even stronger since then to be
fair over that time some of my
perspectives have stayed the same and
some of them have changed either way
I've learned a lot over the last one
year let alone the last four years and
and it's at that point where there's a
lot of stuff I just like to put back out
there into the world and share this time
around though I would like to get the
audience a little bit more involved in
the type of things I talk about and the
content I share so by all means if you
have any ideas drop them down in the
comment section so if you like this
video or you're just generally excited
to see something new for me again smash
the like button and leave a comment down
below or if you disliked it and you're
mortified to see me again then you can
smash the dislike button that's really
up to you then I'll actually see you all
in the not so distant future until then
Richard on data